unter den letzten video gab es
beschwerden darüber dass ich schon
lieber mit dem thema aliens beschäftigt
habe aber außerirdische will man ein
zentraler forschungszweig der
wissenschaft und es wird an allen ecken
und enden nach ihnen gesucht und
vielleicht stehen da unsere chancen
einfach schlecht weil wir einsam sind
weil sich unsere milchstraße in einem
besonders lehrern teil des universums
befindet diensten sprechen nämlich dafür
dass sich unsere galaxie in den größten
bekannten beugt des universums befindet
einen besonders leeren bereich des
weltalls wenn wir also einfach einsam im
weltraum liegt zurzeit häufig schwer zu
bekommen
zugegeben bei ihnen thema spielen aliens
erstmal nur eine geringe rolle aber die
nasa die applikationen usw
wie alle suchen intensiv nach
außerirdischen egal ob marcelos
exoplaneten radiosignale überall wird
nach ihm gesucht werden milliarden in
die forschung gesteckt und da ist es
kein wunder dass es hier immer wieder
auf wachstum um außerirdische das wird
auch so bleiben weil es einfach eines
der ganz großen themen der forschung ist
die menschheit ist unglaublich neugierig
daraus eine der wichtigsten fragen zu
erforschen
seit wir im wahrsten sinne des wortes
denken können sind wir allein im
universum und jetzt gibt es eine
forschungsarbeit die indizien dafür
gesammelt hat dass wir zumindest in
einem sehr sehr leeren bereich des
weltalls sind was natürlich die chancen
auf den ersten kontakt schmälern könnte
aber der reihe nach
das universum ist eigentlich ein ort in
dem die materie gleichmäßig über den
raum verteilt ist das einzig
ungleichmäßige dass wir hier von der
erde aussehen dass uns unsere
milchstraße unsere galaxie wie ich als
helles band über den himmel ziehen aber
das ist mehr eine frage des standen sich
ist die materie regelmäßig versagt doch
es gibt strukturen im weltall die
materie dann doch etwas sortieren und
mit wenigen ländern aus gars
galaxienhaufen und sehr leeren bereichen
den sogenannten beugt das universum
sortieren in den letzten jahren gab es
immer wieder studien die untersucht
haben wo unsere galaxie die milchstraße
eigentlich liegt da wo es richtig eng
wird oder er in einem sehr leeren
bereich in einem wort sie kamen zu dem
ergebnis dass wir eher in einem sehr
leeren bereich des weltalls wiegen wenn
hochscheidt und seine kolleginnen und
kollegen von der university of wisconsin
madison usa werteten jetzt spektrograph
ische daten von objekten in unserer
näheren umgebung und von entfernten
objekten aus und kamen zu einem
spektakulären ergebnis zitat das von uns
ermittelte dichten profil passt zu den
kosmologischen beobachtungen es spricht
dafür dass die milchstraße in einer
großen leere liegt das sagt die
forscherin mitbürger und das absolut
beeindruckende die milchstraße liegt
demnach im größten bisher bekannten
voltaire ist sieben mal größer als
üblicherweise will das würde auch ein
weiteres rätsel der astrophysik lösen
die hubble konstante der wert für die
kosmische expansionsrate der ist je
nachdem ob er anhand der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung oder anhand von
galaxien und supernovae berechnet wird
unterschiedlich zitat eigentlich müsste
man die gleichen werte für die kosmische
expansion frage bekommen egal welche
methode man nutzt aber wenn wir wirklich
in einem wald leben dann könnte dies die
diskrepanzen erklären sagt bahnhof
scheitern würden wir nämlich durch die
ungleiche verteilung der materie in
unserer nähe und weit entfernt dadurch
würden einfach messwerte der
rotverschiebung wird mehr halten wie die
ergebnisse für die messung der habe
konstante beeinflusst aber jetzt muss
erstmal weitere studien geben die die
these des wolfs in dem wir uns befinden
bestätigen oder widerlegen bedingungen
auf das letzte video könnte das ein
grund sein warum uns außerirdische noch
nicht besucht haben
es gibt einfach keine in unserer
umgebung aber auch das ist nur ein
entweder ich bin dagegen
wie die nasa überzeugt davon dass wir
schon bald auf außerirdisches
lebensgroßen werden klüpfel milliarden
in die forschung nach gesteckt werden
ist es wenn es sie gibt
dafür spricht eine menge ziemlich
wahrscheinlich dass sich auch aufgespürt
werden so jetzt seid ihr brand vorbild
sein
der wettbewerb für euch in dem es
insgesamt achtung 21.000 euro gewinn
getrickst vater wir unterstützen das und
die chancen dort will sie stehen echt
nicht schlecht gesucht werden die besten
web videos für die wissenschaft und wenn
ihr das ein wenig kreativ angeht dann
habt ihr wirklich ziemlich große chance
und einfach achtung hier draufklicken da
gibt es alle infos und damit auch genug
zeit zum klicken haushalt ich das video
jetzt machen
bis dann bleibt dran